die erste Frage an Sie wie viele Tage
bleiben wir noch als regierte
Bürgermeisterin naja zunächst einmal
haben wir erfolgreich einen
Koalitionsvertrag verhandelt mit der CDU
auch im Zeitplan um den Netz vorgestellt
das läuft jetzt das Mitgliedervotum der
Berliner SPD am 21 April
naja wenn wir wenn das alles so läuft
wie es geplant ist dann wird es am 27
April die Regierungsneubildung geben und
das heißt es sind jetzt noch ein paar
Tage und
diese Zeit wird genutzt um den
Regierungswechsel gut vorzubereiten und
auch die SPD-Mitglieder zu überzeugen
dafür zu stimmen wie schwer sind das
gefallen dieses dieses Amt einfach so
aufzugeben na das ist natürlich kein
leichter Schritt aber wissen Sie es geht
schon darum zum einen ein Wahlergebnis
zu respektieren und zum anderen dann die
Frage zu stellen was ist der beste Weg
für diese Stadt und was haben die Wähler
eigentlich zum Ausdruck gebracht sie
haben Kritik zum Ausdruck gebracht bei
den Themen bezahlbare Stadt beim Thema
funktionierende Stadt mit dem Thema
Sicherheit Neukölln Silvesternacht ja
das sind eben Dinge gewesen die
Veränderungen bedürfen und die Frage war
dann in den Sondierungen wie bekommen
wir diese Veränderung hin wie bekommen
wir pragmatische Lösungen für die
Probleme dieser Stadt und wer ist dafür
der bessere Partner es wäre ja auch
anders gegangen ja das wäre auch anders
geworden theoretisch Bürgermeisterin
bleiben können das ist korrekt man hätte
zwei Möglichkeiten für parlamentarisch
entschieden weil sie so selbstlos sind
oder weißt du wirklich anders Ihre Frage
suggeriert das ist ja ein völlig
unvorstellbarer Vorgang ist dass jemand
einfach sagt ich schaue mir an wir
schauen uns an als gemeinsames Team als
Team was der beste Weg für die Stadt ist
wie wir das was die Wähler da abgestimmt
haben
Politik dann immer
grundsätzlich abgesprochen auch im Sinne
der Stadt der Gemeinschaft des Landes zu
denken
jetzt am Abend das wahlergebnises
war klar wir werden zwei Möglichkeiten
haben zu sondieren entweder schwarz-rot
oder Rot-Grün-Rot und wir haben von der
Parteien klaren Auftrag bekommen
Präferenz ist Rot-Grün-Rot und dann ist
das sondierungs-team in die Verhandlung
gegangen und wir haben über die
wichtigen Zukunftsfragen der Stadt
gesprochen über Lösungsansätze über die
freiwilligung wollte dass es so
weitergeht wie gehabt naja man muss
schon sehen dass sie eingepartei ja auch
kein homogener Block ist es geht darum
wie wir die Fragen die zukunftsfreien
die Berlin hat gut lösen können und wie
wir auch die SPD in einen Fahrwasser
bringen dass uns gestärkt auch aus den
kommenden drei Jahren hervorgehen lässt
und die Frage ist schon wie adressiert
man auf die großen Themen die die
Berliner kritisiert haben und ich habe
und wir haben das insgesamt als
sondierungs-team so bewertet dass wir
pragmatische lösungsorientierte Politik
in der Situation sind besser mit der CDU
machen können als das bis der Fall war
es braucht Veränderung es braucht einen
Aufruf braucht es braucht Erneuerung und
deswegen war dann die Empfehlung des
sondierungsteams in diese Richtung die
Verhandlung aufzubauen ich fasse noch
mal zusammen also sie hätten es machen
können Ihre eigene Partei an größerer
Teil davon wollte dass sie es machen
dass das so weitergeht und sie haben
dann selbstlos gesagt es geht um was
Größeres es geht um die Stadt geht nicht
um mich es geht um mich besuchen mir ist
wirklich wahr also ich habe
sehr gut informiert ja es geht um die
Entscheidung
der geäußert wurde diese Koalition hat
250.000 Stimmen verloren das muss man
erstmal zur Kenntnis nehmen und da muss
man sich fragen was müssen wir tun um
Vertrauen auch zurück zu gewinnen um zu
sagen ja wir kümmern uns um die
Sicherheit in der Stadt wir kümmern uns
um die funktionierende Stadt wir kümmern
uns um die bezahlbare Stadt um
Mieterschutz und Klimaschutz um
Arbeitnehmerschutz und die Fragen wie
wird das besser hinbekommen die haben
wir uns gestellt insgesamt auch und das
gesamte sondierungsdienst zu dem Schluss
gekommen dass es eine Veränderung
braucht die Fraktionschef sagt das ist
jetzt keine Liebesheirat mit Herrn
Wegener wie ist das für Sie also es geht
dabei nicht um Liebesheirat sondern es
geht um Verantwortung für die Stadt es
geht darum mit welchem Partner man die
Themen die wir angehen müssen jetzt am
besten der ideale Partner für Sie also
wissen Sie wenn ich mir das aussuchen
könnte würde ich gerne alle zehn
Ressorts mit spd-leuten besetzen
absolute Mehrheit das wäre toll die
Realität
die Realität ist eine andere wir haben
sind zwei platzierter geworden in dieser
Wahl und das ist auch gut ja auch gut
schlecht ist das Ergebnis aller Zeiten
sie sagen zwei platzierter ich finde
dass wir zuallerer erstmal eine
Verantwortung für die Stadt haben und es
geht darum Antworten für diese Stadt zu
finden die wirklich ermöglichen dass wir
die Themen die die Stadt hat gut angehen
können und vieles ist auch gelungen ich
würde es auch mal sagen im letzten Jahr
haben wir drei große Krisen gleichzeitig
bewältigt corona-pandemie Berlin war
Haupt Ankunftsort für ukrainische
geflüchtete 380.000 Menschen erst
versorgt wir haben diese ganze
Energiekrise gut gemeistert das ist
gelungen aber es war permanent
wir haben darüber diskutiert und wir
sagten es kann passieren und es ist
nicht passiert und das ist eine Leistung
deutsche Politik ja die erledigt worden
ist das keine Betriebe pleite gegangen
sind dass alle unsere sozialen
Einrichtungen aufrecht erhalten und dass
die Menschen über Härtefall helfen und
alles die Krise auch überwunden haben
und wir insgesamt die Krise wie groß ist
ihre Angst vor dass ihre eigene Basis
sagen wird nicht das machen wir nicht
mit Herrn Wegner haben wir gar keinen
Bock drauf also ich habe in den letzten
Tagen erlebt er mir sehr viele Gespräche
in der Partei auch gefühlt und ich habe
in den letzten Tagen erlebt dass viele
auch gesagt haben wir gucken uns das
jetzt erstmal an was im
Koalitionsvertrag steht der Vertrag ist
jetzt da und da ist eine deutliche
sozialdemokratische Handschriften das
sehen auch viele Bürger also ja man muss
immer sehen ich finde sie haben Sie das
gemacht sie haben so viele sie liegen
zehn Prozent hinter ihm hinterher und
haben genauso viele Senatoren Posten aus
den Rippen geleiert wie wie wie er
selber hat wie haben Sie das gemacht
es ist doch kein Geheimnis der unbedingt
Bürgermeister werden wollte fast jeden
Preis geht doch einfach darum dass wir
schaffen müssen auf Zustimmung für
diesen Vertrag hinzubekommen das geht
darum dass wir auch im Mitgliedervotum
die SPD-Mitglieder überzeugen können und
da kann ich nicht sagen wir kommen
irgendwie mit nichts nach Hause so und
das ist natürlich schon ein Punkt wir
haben jetzt wichtige sozialdemokratische
Vorhaben wir haben starke Ressorts mit
denen man wirklich die Stadt auch
gestalten kann und beim Thema Sicherheit
auch beim Thema
bauliche Entwicklung das sind schon
Punkte die sind wichtig für die Stadt
und die haben mir auch geschafft zu
verhandeln unbedingt
war habe ich noch eine Frage stimmt es
dass sie danach Frau Merkel angerufen
haben nach diesem Schritt ich habe sie
nicht angerufen sie hat mir eine
Nachricht geschickt und wir haben dann
auch noch telefoniert aber ähm und sie
was hat sie hat sie gratuliert zu diesem
Schritt
mein chapeau dass sie es nicht mehr
machen wollen oder chapeau das Kapitel
da jetzt Bürgermeister ist diesen
Schritt zu gehen zu sagen wir haben
einen Wahlergebnis 28 Prozent CDU 18
Prozent SPD ich bin der Überzeugung dass
ein sozialdemokratisches Bündnis mit der
CDU gut für diese Stadt ist wir haben
dafür verhandelt wir haben ein sehr
gutes Ergebnis erzielt und ja dafür gehe
ich einen Schritt zurück um das zu
ermöglichen das ist ja ein
ungewöhnlicher Schritt gesagt auch
chapeau wir haben Olaf Scholz darüber
gesprochen und auch mit der
Parteiführung die Parteiführung hat
gesagt sie werden den Weg den wir für
Berlin verhandeln unterstützen und das
war wichtig Rückendeckung von der
Bundesebene Rückendeckung auch vom
Landesvorstand mehrheitlich nicht 100%
ist ja auch bekannt natürlich gibt es
kontroverse Diskussion aber ich glaube
dass am Ende die Mitglieder der Berliner
SPD sagen das ist ein guter Vertrag wir
haben damit die Möglichkeit zu regieren
und zu gestalten und das ist wichtig
dass es besser als Opposition das muss
man auch ganz klar sagen denn ich möchte
nicht den Weg gehen hätten wir auch
machen können aus der Opposition
zuzuschauen wie Schwarz-Grün regiert ich
glaube nicht dass das Berlin gut tut ich
glaube das hätte zu großen Verwerfungen
geführt und die soziale Komponente der
Politik in der Stadt wäre verloren
gegangen deswegen ganz klar es ist und
wenn ihr SPD mit regierte dafür haben
wir gearbeitet okay also erstmal Respekt
das so zu machen weil ich sehr smart
aber die große Frage ist warum Herr
Brücke wie selbstlos war warum ist Olaf
Scholz auch kurz vor Chapo SMS in
Richtung Franziska gefallen warum findet
er das richtig gut was da jetzt was also
zunächst mal würde ich Frau zugestehen
und ich beobachte sie auch länger und
glaube dass das auch stimmt dass jetzt
aus ihren Poren nicht ausschließlich
macht Geilheit strömt jeden Tag und sie
unbedingt ein Ämtern klebt wie es ihr
teilweise vorgeworfen wird aber die gibt
natürlich noch zusätzliche Wahrheiten zu
diesem Schritt und die eine ist erstmal
das Feld ist von ihr und Frau jarasch
ist gar nicht mehr zu beschreiben so
nicht vorhanden ist dieses Verhältnis
das ein weiterführen mit Frau jarasch in
Rot-Rot-Grün ihr körperliche Schmerzen
bereiten würde was sie jetzt sicherlich
zugibt aber vom Teil der Wahrheit ist
Teil der Wahrheit ist versuche gerade
körperliche Reaktionen ich habe noch
zwei andere Argumente
okay ich
konnte
erstmal fertig ja gut er merkt sich
sowieso alles immer das ist egal
das zweite Argument ist ein
strategisches und deswegen hat die
Bundes SPD zwar am Anfang gesagt wer hat
es mehr hat probiert das ruhig aber in
Wahrheit freut sich die SPD im Bund und
der Bundeskanzler auch sehr darüber dass
Schwarz Rot in Berlin möglich ist weil
der Automatismus in den Länder den in
den letzten Monaten erlebt haben zu
schwarz grün aufgebrochen wird wenn dort
jetzt schwarz rot herrscht das
strategische die strategische Debatte in
Deutschland findet gerade statt wer ist
die zentrale Kraft in der politischen
Linken man hat das im
Koalitionsausschuss auf der Bundesebene
gesehen da geht es grün gegen Rot rot
gegen Grün das Kanzleramt ist maximal
genervt von auch der Anspruchshaltung
manche in der SPD sagen Hybris der
Grünen bei bestimmten Themen insofern
tut denen das Gut lieber mit den
schwarzen noch mal ein gegenbündnis zu
bilden als wieder mit den Grünen den
Vortritt zu lassen das wäre ja die
Alternative schwarz grün die hat mir
auch gute Sondierungen und dann hat Frau
giffe 3 Momentum einen roten
Koalitionsvertrag hinbekommen wirklich
das ist eigentlich ein links Bündnis in
Berlin mit einem schwarzen Bürgermeister
den ersten 50 60 Seiten habe ich
wirklich Begriffe gesucht die die CDU
begeistern könnte da ist dann erstmal
von querbeauftragten geredet und
Kommission zu antimus limischen
Rassismus und diversity Checks alles was
die SPD liebt was auch richtig und
wunderbar ist aber die CDU würde ganz
gerne einen Plan beauftragten haben
anstatt einen querbeauftragten das kommt
Wort kommt aber gar nicht vor also so
ungefähr läuft das im gesamten
Koalitionsvertrag dann geht doch das
innen Resort mit dem die CDU ja den
Wahlkampf gewonnen hat auch noch an die
SPD also die ist die eigentlich müsste
die CDU-Basis
alles egal Hauptsache ich werde
Bürgermeister die Wahrheit ist das die
CDU relativ programmatisch unvorbereitet
in diese Koalitionsverhandlungen
gegangen ist oder sehr flexibel man kann
das so oder so sehen jedenfalls hat kein
Wegner nur die Chance Bürgermeister zu
werden wenn müssen wir das Gesicht von
Frau giffe ein großer Aufnahme anfangen
Koalitionsvertrag und Kai Wegner wie
gesagt wenn der eine basisbefragung
machen würde gelb sicherlich ziemlich
viel Gegenwind insofern ist das ein
Vertrag den eigentlich die SPD-Basis gar
nicht ablehnen kann so viel
Sozialdemokratie steckt da drin
inklusive ein
vergesellschaftungsgesetz das ist das
Gegenteil von dem was jeder CDU
Politiker morgens um 6 Uhr sagt wenn er
geweckt wird ja wollt ihr
Vergesellschaftung von Firma haben um
den Wohnungs und Bau in Probleme in der
Stadt zu lösen und sagt nein bitte auf
keinen Fall jetzt steht's im Vertrag
Gesellschaft
wurde im Wahlkampf versprochen also die
sie haben das geschickt gemacht
politisch extrem klug und wenn ihre
eigene Basis da nicht da nicht mit
stimmt dann müssen Sie mit dieser Basis
eigentlich auch nichts mehr zu tun dazu
passt ja sehr interessant das Anton
Hofreiter gesagt die die Scholz spds
nicht mehr der natürliche Verbündete der
Grünen
er spricht aus was viele da denken ja
das heißt da gibt es in Wahrheit einen
einen links einen links linken
Machtkampf
die zentrale politische Linke zu sein
Robert Habeck hat das in seinen Büchern
formuliert sagt das auch die wollen die
SPD ablösen und es ist nun mal Fleisch
vom Fleisch was diese beiden Parteien
wählt und insofern kann die ist das auch
legitim von den Grünen das zu sagen wir
sind die moderne Linke und die SPD möge
gerne platzierter bleiben was heißt in
Wahrheit geht es darum was ganz anderes
in Wahrheit geht es darum die Grünen
klein zu halten in Wahrheit geht um die
Wiederwahl von Olaf Scholz das spielt
sicherlich auch eine Rolle und Frau
Käfer hat ja selber den aus meiner Sicht
kluge
gemacht ein Schritt zurück in Wahrheit
aber vielleicht in drei Jahren zwei
wieder nach vorne zu gehen denn wenn sie
jetzt Rot-Rot-Grün gemacht hätte einen
medialen Shitstorm sondergleichen wenn
ein Wal Verlierer und alle drei Parteien
haben verloren und die bilden wieder ein
Bündnis das mag man in Deutschland zu
Recht nicht und die Medien wären egal ob
links oder rechts werden draufgegangen
auf dieses Bündnis und ich glaube nicht
dass Frau giffe als regieren eines
Linksbündnis in drei Jahren plötzlich
plus 10% bekommen hätte halte ich für
ausgeschlossen insofern ist der Schritt
den sie geht's ziemlich klug vielleicht
als Bau oder innensenatorin das wird sie
uns ja vielleicht noch verraten in drei
Jahren im Wahlkampf gegen einen
vielleicht blassen Bürgermeister weiß
man ja nicht doch noch wieder nach vorne
zu kommen oder ist das die Idee
vorgefallen also zunächst einmal jedes
Bündnis ist immer ein Bündnis auf Zeit
und man muss das richtige Bündnis zur
richtigen Zeit finden mit dem man die
Dinge die notwendig sind tun kann ich
bin nach wie vor der Meinung Franz
Müntefering Opposition ist der hatte
Recht und deswegen wenn man regeln kann
muss man das tun man muss es mit den
Partner tun mit denen man was ist nein
denen man etwas erreicht für die Stadt
für das Land mit denen man aber auch
eine Perspektive eröffnen kann für die
eigene Profilierung und die SPD ist die
soziale Kraft in der Stadt und es ist
notwendig dass wir jetzt diese
Profilierung auch machen damit wir
gestärkt aus dieser wissen Sie ich sehe
das ja auch wir haben ein sehr bitteres
Wahlergebnis gehabt und da kann man
nicht einfach so weitermachen
wir haben im letzten Jahr professionell
zusammengearbeitet und schlimmer geht's
nicht ne naja also ich sag mal dass das
natürlich dann ab dem Zeitpunkt ab dem
klar war es gibt diese Wiederholungswahl
ein auch teilweise erbitterter Kampf war
um die Frage wer wird die Führung im
Roten Rathaus übernehmen das ist doch
ganz klar denn das wollte sie auch beim
letzten Mal die sie wollte dass die
Grünen die stärkste Kraft werden und ab
dem Moment wo klar war dass wir diese
Wiederholungsfall haben
war das schwierig mit der Zusammenarbeit
ist doch klar
es ist doch so wir haben weiter unsere
senatsarbeit gemacht und ich wirklich
ich stehe sehr Bürgermeisterin
Frau jarasch unter Lederer sind meine
Stellvertreter als Bürgermeister und es
geht darum das habe ich auch immer
gesagt wir haben die Verantwortung für
die Stadt so lange bis eine neue
Landesregierung eingesetzt und deshalb
muss professionell zusammengearbeitet
werden aber dass man natürlich wenn man
zeitgleich im Wahlkampf ist Vormittag
Senatssitzung abends Podiumsdiskussion
im Wahlkampf dann ist das eine
angespannte Situation ich glaube das
kann auch jeder nachvollziehen
ich weiß nicht ich weiß dass sie gerne
dass dieses Diskussion in die Richtung
gehen
also ich meine man tritt doch an und und
versucht ein wenn wir es ein
progressives Bündnis ja man versucht die
Stadt irgendwie voran zu bringen und wir
haben auch eine Menge geschafft wissen
ich will das wirklich normal sagen
also man hat einerseits diese
Zusammenarbeit im Senat die davon
getragen sein muss dass jeder seine
Aufgaben ordentlich macht und dass man
professionell zusammenarbeitet ich
glaube dafür sind wir auch erwachsen
genug dass wir das hinbekommen haben
dass das jetzt kein inniges Verhältnis
ist wenn man in einer derartigen
Konkurrenzsituation ist das ist glaube
ich nachvollziehbar und trotzdem würde
ich sagen dass wir wirklich das so gut
es unter diesen schwierigen Umständen
ging gemacht haben um Berlin auch über
diese krisenhaften Situation zu bringen
und das ist ja gelungen wir haben im
letzten Jahr der stärkste
Wirtschaftswachstum bundesweit gehabt
wir haben viele viele geflüchtete in der
Stadt aufgenommen und auch diese großen
Problemlagen haben sie das gleiche Thema
wieder mit Herrn Wegner
also auch jeder dann vorne sein sie
haben jetzt genau die gleiche Situation
wir haben Sie bald wieder naja es ist
doch immer so wenn eine neue
Landesregierung sich im Wahlkampf
befindet dann ist es auch eine
Wettbewerbssituation der man ist aber
wir haben jetzt hier den Sonderfall
gehabt dass nach einem Jahr schon nach
einem Krisenjahr wieder eine Wahl war
und diese Wiederholungswahl an sich zu
einem Zeitpunkt der Krisenbewältigung
und gleichzeitig eben nach so kurzer
Zeit wo einfach ein Plan den man für 5
Jahre gemacht hat noch nicht alle
Ergebnisse aufzählen kann das sind
erschwerte Bedingungen und die werden
nächstes Mal sicher sein für sie auch so
ein Tiefpunkt gewesen also ich meine das
bald kriegen wir OCD Wahlbeobachter
geschickt würden wenn wir nicht mal mehr
da ist in die waren ja schon bitte die
waren ja schon da
also ich bin ja verantwortlich gewesen
für diese Wiederholungswahl es sind
keine Wahlbeobachter geschickt worden
wir hatten eine Erklärung ich kann Ihnen
sagen die Wahlwiederholung die in meiner
Verantwortung geschehen ist ist
reibungslos verlaufen
die letzte Wahl war nicht immer ja das
ist etwas wovon ich natürlich auch
selber betroffen bin ich war Kandidatin
ich habe diese Wahl gewonnen man geht
davon aus dass es fünf Jahre sind und
dann gibt es so eine Situation das ist
natürlich eine problematische Situation
es darf auch nie wieder vorkommen bitte
ist ja schon schlimm genug dass man mit
OECD Wahl Beobachtern vorab reden muss
damit sie bloß nicht erscheinen am
Wahltag weil das ja natürlich Gespräche
vorher ja ich kann Ihnen aber sagen alle
unsere Freunde unsere Vorbereitungen
wir machen das schon vertraut uns wir
haben diese Gespräche gab es mit der
inselnaturen und nicht schlecht ja aber
Sie müssen auch das Ergebnis sehen es
ist reibungsloser sie kann nicht das ist
reibungslos verlaufen und es ist ähm
Deutschland ich meine ich kann Ihnen nur
sagen das was in meiner Verantwortung
gewesen ist so weil wir Erholung ist
reibungslos verlaufen wir haben letztes
Jahr drei Jahre Verantwortung aber das
Michael Müller das war in der
vorhergehenden Legislatur und ich wissen
Sie ich finde es immer schwierig einer
Person an die Verantwortung dafür
umzuhängen es sind da war ich nicht es
sind viele Fehler passiert die auf
unterschiedlichen Stellen es gab
umfangreiche Analysen wir haben eine
neue Landeswahlleiter eingesetzt in
meiner Verantwortung und diese Fehler
sind aufgearbeitet worden deshalb ist
die Wiederholungswahl auch reibungslos
verlaufen weil wir nämlich auf das
gehört haben was dort an Fehlern war und
das auch verbessert haben okay aber das
mit der ist interessant wusste ich nicht
wie läuft so was rufen die an und sagen
und wir müssen mal reden wir müssen
eigentlich Leute schicken aber wir
trauen uns nicht so richtig weil
eigentlich das ist alles über die
zuständige Insel Naturin gelaufen das
waren Vorgespräche und die sind ganz ähm
ja auch nüchtern abgelaufen und dann war
klar es ist alles gut vorbereitet wir
haben ein professionellen
Landeswahlleiter und das ist gut
gelaufen
eine inhaltliches Thema auch noch mal
ich das gerade gesagt sie sind ja jemand
der sehr verwurzelt ist in Neukölln und
sehr beliebt dort immer gewesen und zwar
dann verlieren sie das Direktmandat in
Köln
und stellt sich raus auch erstaunlich
viele Migranten die dort leben wählen
die CDU wie ist das zu erklären mir ist
das passiert was allen Abgeordneten der
SPD im äußeren Ring Berlins passiert ist
wir haben ja eine Situation in der man
wenn man drauf schaut auf die Karte so
eine Art donutsituation entstanden ist
in grün außen ein schwarzer Ring und
dieser schwarze Ring war eben die
Zustimmung zur eher zur CDU und das
liegt an sich den essentiellen Themen
die die Leute gestört haben es ging um
das Thema Verkehr es ging um das Thema
Sicherheit es ging um das Thema
funktionierende Stadt aber auch
bezahlbarer Wohnraum und das waren die
großen vier Felder in denen es
Veränderungen braucht und wo auch klar
war wenn wir jetzt ein neues Bündnis
eingehen dann müssen wir deutlich
Veränderung in diesem Bereichen zeigen
und dann war auch klar in den Sondierung
so wie es bisher war kann es nicht
weitergehen und ich habe mich das
wirklich gefragt was müssen wir tun um
dem Wähler Willen auch der
Unzufriedenheit die zum Ausdruck
gekommen ist gerecht zu werden und
deshalb ist die Ausbildung so gefallen
wir haben jetzt einen Vertrag
ausgehandelt hat der Herr Bürger gut aus
gearbeitet wo ich wirklich mit zufrieden
sein kann ich bin sehr davon überzeugt
dass wir es auch schaffen dass viele
Sozialdemokraten das auch so sehen die
Frage warum Neukölln dieses Ergebnis in
Neuköln ist doch wirklich interessant
und natürlich hat das mit der
Silvesternacht zu tun wir haben ja wie
viele andere Medien auch Journalisten
natürlich nach Neukölln geschickt und
einmal mit den Menschen zu reden unter
anderem ja die Integrationsbeauftragte
die sie gut kennen die Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte in diesem Stadtteil
zweite dritte Generation alles Deutsche
ganz klar die haben ja selber ich sag
mal in unseren Worten die Schnauze voll
von den Halbstarken andere sagen hier
auf diesem Studio andere sagen zu diesen
jungen Männern die teilweise natürlich
nicht alle aber teilweise
navigationsgeschichte haben die auch
eine kulturelle Ablehnung der
Autoritäten in diesem Staat beinhalten
das ist eben Teil der Wahrheit und die
sind selber genervt von diesen Jungs
ich wünsche mir da mehr Härte des
deutschen Staates sagen uns diese Leute
und die haben die SPD nicht gewählt das
ist das Problem weil die SPD genauso
verschwurbelt darüber geredet hat über
diese Silvesternacht wie sie sonst gerne
tut wenn irgendwie irgendetwas mit
Migrationsgeschichte thematisiert wird
mal ausnahmsweise im Negativen Kontext
dann wird darüber nicht ehrlich geredet
und das haben die die Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte den eigenen SPD mal
gezeigt sorry wir sind zwar keine
cdu-fans aber das was ihr da jetzt
gemacht habt das ist auch nicht mehr das
verstehen wir nicht mehr geht mit den
Jungs ordentlich um weil die brauchen
das was ein anderer möglicher neuer
Kultursenator neulich gesagt hat die
brauchen taff love da muss man eine
klare Ansage kommen da müssen wir
Strafen folgen und das heißt auch nicht
dass man irgendwie rassistisch agiert
sondern man agiert einfach rechts
staatlich klar und das hat die SPD aus
meiner Sicht eben und Aussicht wieder
dieser Menschen da auf man nicht getan
letzten Jahr hat er recht
ich glaube es ist natürlich das ist ein
Teil der Antwort ich finde immer
schwierig wenn man anfängt wirklich alle
über einen Kampf zu führen deshalb haben
sie auch nicht gemacht sage ich auch
nicht aber einige haben das gemacht in
der Debatte dass man eben gesagt hat
alle Migranten so und so und da gab es
große Kritik auch aus der es gab eine
die klar gesagt haben natürlich und das
habe ich auch gesagt diese das sind
Straftaten die müssen konsequent
verfolgt keine Frage aber konsequent wir
haben die Polizei hat der Ermittlungen
aufgenommen wie viele Verfahren laufen
jetzt heute heutigen Tag wir haben über
40 Verfahren die aufgenommen worden sind
es gibt auch Einstellung von verfahren
wir haben aktuell
sind also wir haben 20 Einstellung von
verfahren wir haben Strafe viele die
sind verhängt worden einige Verfahren
laufen auch noch es ist schwierig die
Beweislage zu ermitteln in einer so nach
wie sie da gerade dieses zeigen 40
Verfahren führt sie Verfahren sind
übergeben worden von der Polizei nach
der Ermittlung es gab ja 20 eingestellt
oder wir haben 20 Einstellungen von
Verfahren das heißt am Ende bleiben
jetzt 20 übrig 20 ja nachdem was da
passiert ist noch laufen es gibt noch
kein einziges Urteil und es geht auch
gar nicht um in haftname es geht doch
nur darum dass ein Urteil und eine
Strafe überhaupt mal gefällt wird und
warum passiert das nicht das ist eine
Konsequenz eine Konsequenz
warum passiert das nicht weil es keine
Videoüberwachung dort gibt weil es keine
bodycams bei dem Polizisten gab weil die
Menschen sich gegenseitig eben offenbar
aber natürlich auch nicht verpfeifen
wollen offenbar ist die beweislastsicher
und das Thema aber
solche Leute zu finden genau der Punkt
warum ich auch gesagt habe wir brauchen
beim Thema Sicherheit auch an bestimmten
Stellen eine andere Politik und das ist
auch ein Grund vorschlagen
Koalitionsvertrag jetzt mit der CDU
Dinge vereinbart die eine verstärkte
Ausstattung von Polizei und Feuerwehr
mit Body Camps mit auch der Möglichkeit
der Strafverfolgung bis in die
Privatwohnungen hinein in der zum
Beispiel dann auch die bodycams
eingesetzt werden können im privaten
Bereich natürlich mit Vorwarnung
die generelle Frage der Ausstattung auch
der Feuerwehr wir haben in den
Polizeiautos ja die und in den
Feuerwehrwagen nicht überall die Kamera
Ausstellung das muss sich verändern wir
brauchen dort eine verstärkte
Ausstellung das ist Vereinbarung sagen
Sie was heißt das Präventivhaft heißt
das wenn Sie wissen sie haben Menschen
die
potentiell an bestimmten Tagen gefährden
sein können
dass sie dann eben die Menschen
präventiv in ähm was gemacht hat wenn
eine andere von einer Straftat vorliegt
dass sie eben vorbeugend in Haft nehmen
können da gibt's im Moment in Berlin
drei Tage wir haben jetzt vereinbart
dass das auf fünf Tage hochgesetzt
werden soll da gibt's im Bundesgebiet
ganz unterschiedliche der der erkennbar
vor den Augen von Polizei der der der
schießt auf Polizisten auf
Feuerwehrmänner auf Rettungssanitäter
und hat bis jetzt Karl zu Kanada
Konsequenz geführt wir werden also so
jemand ist denkt man darüber andere
Dinge gesprochen ich glaube Herr Brücke
war aus der sagte nimm den doch einfach
mal den Führerschein weg z.B das tut weh
sie haben unterhalb der inhaftnahme
haben sie ja auch andere Möglichkeiten
und wir haben ja deswegen auch den
Gipfel gegen Jugend Gewalt einberufen
haben mit Polizei mit den Einsatzkräften
mit Sozialarbeitern zusammen Maßnahmen
arbeitet um präventiv zu wirken diese
Maßnahmen sind jetzt auch in Kraft dafür
ist Geld bereitgestellt auch in der
präventiven Jugendarbeit in der Frage
der gefährdungsansprache in der Frage
der der Schulsozialarbeit und es gibt
bei Minderjährigen Tätern die eine Reihe
von Möglichkeiten bevor sie in Gewahrsam
oder in Haft jemand nehmen und ich
glaube schon dass es wichtig ist diese
entscheiden auch voll auszuschöpfen fakt
ist dass wir später in Richtung Justiz
die schöpfen das nicht aus oder wer
schöpft das nicht aus
der Bundesjustizminister war vor einiger
Zeit hier und sagte wir haben all die
Gesetze aber wir bringen sie irgendwie
nicht zur Anwendung
wo sie keine Beweise haben deswegen ist
das Thema Beweisführung so wichtig
deswegen ist das Thema bodycam so
wichtig deswegen haben wir jetzt im
Koalitionsvertrag und auch eine
Ausweitung
verankert damit wir eben auch besser
Beweise sichern können um strafverfolgen
auch zu Ende zu führen ja ich spüre
sozusagen die das was da
nonverbal noch alles mitschwingt
irgendwie ist das quält sie ja richtig
dieses ganze Thema ich liebe es anders
machen ich kann verstehen dass Menschen
erwarten dass wenn jemand solche
Straftaten begeht dass die konsequente
Strafe folgen
und dann macht man solche Dinge und es
bleibt weitestgehend ohne Konsequenz das
kannst doch nicht sein wirklich nicht
wir haben bei den Taten wo wir
zweifelsfrei den mitnehmen können wo wir
das zuordnen können wo die Beweislage
stimmt da können wir auch gegen vorgehen
aber wenn Sie die Beweislage eben nicht
in der Form haben dann haben sie
begrenzte Möglichkeiten deshalb müssen
wir uns Gedanken darüber machen wie
Polizei Feuerwehr Rettungskräfte so
ausgestattet werden dass sie das tun
können Ihr Thema Frauen und das war ich
habe das immer auch angefangen auf
konsequentes Vorgehen
natürlich das sind wichtige Themen und
die müssen auch angehen und deswegen ist
es auch einer der Gründe die Leute haben
sich Sicherheit gewünscht und viele
haben deswegen so entschieden und
deswegen müssen wir an dieser Stelle
auch Veränderungen Anliegen das Thema ja
und sie würden gerne das ein oder andere
anders machen das heißt
könnten Sie sich vorstellen mal
bundesinnenministerin zu werden
also
ich würde mal sagen wir haben heute hier
eine Diskussion über einen sehr gut
ausgehandelten Koalitionsvertrag über
ein mögliches Bündnis und ich habe
gesagt ich möchte gerne in diesem
Bündnis mitarbeiten und das ist das
brauchen sie sich ich mich orientiere
könnten Sie sich das vorstellen
bundesinnenministerin es steht überhaupt
nicht zu Debatte im Moment ausschließen
ich finde diese ausschließerei und ja
über irgendwelche Posten sie hätten
gerade nichts anderes zu tun das würde
gerade zu Disposition stehen
und sagen Franziska sie nutzen sich ja
als wir die du uns mal ja wir brauchen
das Land braucht Dich da können sie doch
nicht sagen Olaf es lass mal ich glaube
jetzt steht an das berlin-missbraucht
ich möchte gerne für meine Stadt was tun
und der Vorschlag dafür liegt auf dem
Tisch ich hoffe dass die SPD diesen Weg
mitgeht und das ist die konzentrieren